hey what's up everybody how you guys
doing welcome welcome to another stream
this is episode 20 we've done this 20
weekends in a row it's pretty crazy it's
pretty nuts I'm gonna try something a
little different today well I guess it
won't be entirely different for you guys
but I figure you know I'll spend you
know just five minutes letting everyone
kind of trickle in and you know kick it
off a little slower than as opposed to
just jumping right in and then I'll
actually cut out this intro in the
actual video once I post it you know
just so it's a little bit more personal
for you guys but also if you're coming
back later to watch the video you know
we just get right into it and it's just
a straight tutorial you know but yeah
how's everybody doing is a really really
rough intense week I mean it's been a
it's been a crazy year actually so I
just hope you guys are safe I hope you
guys are feeling okay
I know it's definitely some some tough
times and it's very difficult things
going on this week so you know hopefully
you guys are doing okay so yeah how you
guys doing this week are you guys
excited to learn today we're talking
about advanced shaders in cinema 4d and
octane will be my renderer of choice but
you know it honestly doesn't matter what
renderer you're using or what program
you're using this is basically I'm gonna
talk to you guys about how to make these
textures this is a rusted cast iron
texture if you guys have a cast iron pan
or like a cast iron teapot this is
actually based off of my cast iron
teapot and it gets these like rusted
orange rusty little spots all around it
and this is all made from just noise
Maps you know if you guys have ever used
substance designer it's the same thing
it's just you know creating realistic
textures from noise Maps and that's a
physically-based texture a PBR image
here or not image but yeah it's it's a
it's basically it's not using any like
JPEG
any pictures that's all just clean noise
maps so it's fully editable fully
adjustable and same for this guy this
guy here is based off of my car after it
rained and it was dirty so I wanted to
make some cool like you know dirty rain
texture and figure that one out this one
is actually using one image that's a
Cornelius Dominic image for the rain
because that's a very specific kind of
texture there so that's the only thing
and it's a free image we can all get
that and yeah the depth of field isn't
really helping me on this texture here
but I think I mean adds a little bit of
a cinema cinematic style to it so we'll
just be breaking down these two textures
here and yeah well just again will let
people trickle in see how people are
doing how how you been with corridor
lately yeah things are fun we're
actually I'm working on this world's
biggest Domino video right now we pretty
much finished all of filming yesterday
and it was a rough three days well rough
two days of filming is just running
around all day running running running
with a giant Domino like a domino the
size of my body with ran and with Niko
so the next two weeks will be crunch
town USA on the VFX for that we got some
tricky shots that we got to work on so
yeah I'm sure there'll be a cool BTS on
that you know Nick who runs the corridor
crew channel he he'll probably feature a
lot of the you know VFX techniques and
everything you know as we go down that
and also I think it's not a hundred
percent official because it hasn't
happened yet but I did talk with Chris
Schmidt from rocket lasso and I think
he's gonna be down to help us out with
these VFX he's the master of simulation
and you know I was talking with him on
the phone and he said that he would love
to help out and we want to do like a
little BTS segment on him so I think
that's gonna be
for you guys
yeah PBR mosiac PBR can be complicated
but that's why it's called advanced PBR
textures we're gonna build this stuff
from scratch it's gonna be really fun
and you know hopefully I can do it
perfectly
but you guys you guys know me I I get my
multiply my adds my subtract subtract
nodes mixed up a little bit sometimes so
you know we'll do our best but yeah
we'll get there any other questions you
know
well people trickle in here how has
getting back to the studio been um
honestly guys I love working from home
so so so so much
so much it's the best I'm happier
working from home I have more time
working from home I'm more focused
working from home so you know going back
to the studio is definitely a change for
me it's nice to see people certainly but
when I really want to focus and get work
done and crunch like it's easiest for me
to work in a quiet atmosphere which at
home is exactly that so yeah it's it's
um it's kind of a give and take for me
alright render warrior is this gonna be
a 1 hour or 5 hour stream good question
this will probably be in between this
might be like a two and a half hour
stream cuz you know there's there
there's we got these two textures to
make and they're gonna be pretty
advanced I made these months ago to be
honest with you guys and I don't recall
how long it took me to make them I think
it was like a day or so but um I'm
thinking that I can I can do it on the
stream here with you guys today you know
I did it once I can do it again a little
bit faster hopefully yep yep everyone's
hairs growing out I got my hair growing
out here I got this hair clip going on
it's the best I don't have to gel my
hair I have to do my hair I just hair
clip and I'm done it's great
any other questions guys before we get
going um yeah I love the stuntman react
video awesome thanks for watching yeah
I'm such a huge fan of I mean I did
martial arts from age 9 to 19 and it was
such a huge part of my my childhood and
my upbringing and it kind of shaped Who
I am today to be honest and without it I
wouldn't be the person I am without
martial arts and I am I'm very very
thankful for it it taught me a lot
work ethic discipline respect you know
taking care of my body being able to
train you know stretches stretching it
was the first time anything or anyone
told me hey you need a stretch so yeah
like I grew up watching martial arts
movies of course Jackie Chan was
basically my childhood with movies you
know it's just Jackie Chan Bruce Lee so
and I actually last night I watched 36
chambers of Shaolin for the very first
time I don't know if you guys know that
movie but it was it was legit really
good so I'd actually love to talk about
a scene from that movie on the next um
and react but yeah if you guys don't
know what I'm talking about go to
corridor crew on YouTube and look at our
latest video and we break down awesome
fights in cinema Hollywood you know and
you know just basically break it down
and we get a professional to come on and
and we ask questions and they have a lot
to contribute so that's what that's what
we're talking about if you guys don't
know what we're talking about yeah
anything else anything else I'm using
c4d yeah mm-hmm
an episode on blender I unfortunately
I'm not gonna make an episode on blender
until I know blender well enough to give
info on blender that isn't just you know
stuff you can look up on tutorials and
I'm not just you know spitting out other
people's tutorial videos
honestly the next thing I'll be doing
here throughout the year is I'm
reworking on Unreal Engine if you guys
can see it is my most recent installed
program down here
Unreal Engine it is the future and I am
diving in deep Sam actually gave me a
really nice rundown of all the things he
learned in unreal
yesterday you know cuz he made the video
gamers react video on corridor crew or
it was actually on corridor and he did
it entirely in unreal by himself it took
him like two and a half months and he
learned a whole lot going through that
so I kind of picked his brain yesterday
and he gave me a lot of great info and
winbush is another guy if you guys don't
know winbush he's here on youtube he
also just started a discord channel or a
discord server and he's got some really
nice unreal tutorials so I'm gonna be
working on his tutorials as well and
learning unreal so you guys hopefully by
the end of the serie will see me
streaming some unreal tutorials for you
guys I think it's the future I think
it's the way to go and I think it's
gonna just make the kind of work I love
doing the photo real environments just
so much easier and so much faster what
you advise to make your job hmm um
Eduardo what advice to make my job like
are you saying what advice do I have to
do the job I'm doing I
I mean if that's what you're asking I
just say do what you find entertaining
to yourself what you find interesting
and and just basically follow your
passion and continue doing that you know
I really believe in consistency and
that's something that I've been trying
to keep up with these streams
doing it once every week for well not
just me we you know you guys have been
coming back to these things weekly which
is really cool it'd be a lot less cool
if it was just you know no one watching
is me just talking to nobody so I really
appreciate you guys but yeah basically I
think if you do anything you're
passionate about consistently for a long
period of time it will pay off and
that's what I'm hoping with these
streams here
that it just builds and grows and grows
and that's what that's what I mean Joe
Rogan did for his podcast and look he
just signed a deal with Spotify for 100
plus million so it's just an example and
he talks about it too as he says I've
been working on this this podcast for 10
years and just consistently doing the
podcast for 10 years and it was just fun
for him talking with his friends and and
I want to keep that fresh for you guys
as well I was actually saying how like
it's been difficult to come up with with
things to stream over these last couple
weeks because I've been so busy I hadn't
had any time to put any thought into the
streams yeah it's just so much so
there's so much work there's so much
going on that I want to make sure that
these streams are as fresh as possible
for you guys and you guys are getting as
much out of these streams as possible so
the discord server the links in the
description below like that really helps
so if you guys have anything that you
want to learn just at me in the discord
server like in general chat or something
or whatever and just you know give me
some give me some pointers on what you
guys want to learn here obviously you
know I was talking about doing like a
little secret kind of window through a
power outlet you guys probably seen that
video I think they posted it someone
posted it in the discourse server where
you open up a power outlet like a little
door and you look through and there's
like a room inside I still want to do
that there's just a lot of prep work
that goes into that tutorial and I just
didn't have time this week so we're
breaking down advanced textures ago I
think that's enough
enough intro so I'm gonna just like roll
it back and start this for you know the
people watching this video after the
fact I'll cut out that whole beginning
stuff and we'll get right into this
tutorial in like two seconds
alright alright guys welcome back that
was that was that was a weak intro guys
welcome back welcome back we're doing it
again guys we are talking about advanced
PBR textures in cinema 4d octane now
here's the thing don't run away if you
don't have cinema 4d or you don't have
octane if you're using some other
program stay seated right because these
tips alright what we're about to do
we're about to make these two textures
these are some advanced textures mixed
materials going on they can be these
tips can be applied to any program any
renderer these these images are just
made up from noise Maps you know minus
the rain texture here which we're gonna
get from Cornelius Dominic's website
it's free but you know it's it's the
same concept applies throughout all
programs all renderers you guys gonna be
able to make some really cools and
really advanced textures from just noise
maps and i'm gonna show you guys how to
do that so first thing i did here you
know like I go around my day-to-day life
and I am kind of obsessed with like
looking at textures I'll just note
certain things certain textures around
and I'll take pictures of them and I'll
be like huh I wonder how I would make
that in octane or if you're in substance
you know how would you create that
texture how would you make it look real
so I always start with a reference image
right so um let's see here where are we
let's go my octane textures we'll start
with a cast iron okay
reference so here's the reference I have
a teapot cast iron teapot that my
girlfriend got me for my birthday
and you know it's a cast iron teapot and
I thought hey that's a really cool
texture look at the way like the thing
rusts and oxidizes here it gets this
like orange build up it's really cool
and it's actually pretty intricate you
know you have these little splotches of
orange and the outside is kind of a
milky ER saturate more less saturated
kind of pale orange
as we get closer to the inside you have
this really nice bright orange which is
cool and there's a there's so much
detail there's actually strips of
brighter orange if you look really close
oh excuse me and even on the inside
there's that darker brownish orange
right so that's we're gonna create that
texture and then we also have just the
cast iron itself right so that's why I
got you know this other reference image
here of the cast iron itself and this is
pretty simple actually it's just you
know a noise map or two in the bump
channel and I'd say it's a glassy
definitely a glassy material with the
roughness cranked up so this is pretty
simple and I'd even say that creating
this orange rust material is pretty
simple it's just the way we blend
between the two all right so we're gonna
use a mix material and it's going to
combine our cast iron and it's also
gonna combine this orange rust and then
we're going to use a series of noise
Maps or noise nodes to blend between
both of those textures and that's how
you're getting like the splotches you
know so that'll be the first material we
create you guys can see it here you know
the depth of field isn't really helping
me to show the texture here but yeah and
you can also see that it's happening
this one rust is only happening on the
top where like water would be making
contact down towards the bottom you're
not really gonna have too much rust
because the water is not going to
collect there but here and the crevices
the water might collect now over here we
have a this is a dirty like car paint
texture it's actually a wet wet dirty
rain texture and I was just filling up
my car with gas one day and I have a
white car and it rained and it was dirty
and I was looking at I was like huh
that's really a really cool texture
I would love to create that and see if I
can and I don't know
if I have the reference for that I don't
think I have the reference for that but
dang it's somewhere deep but yeah here's
here's like another example I'll just be
walking around like Oh chip the wall
cool I'll try and recreate this but yeah
let's start with that cast-iron texture
so yeah you guys let me let me switch it
over here we'll get the stream set up
going all right all right
let's render this dude Jim Jam and keys
I got you all right don't worry nodes
it's the best thing ever
all right it's also the future so don't
be scared let's dive into the things we
don't know let's learn the things we
don't know and up our skills here
because that's how we're gonna learn we
got it we got to dive into the unknown a
little bit right but don't worry I got
you guys so yeah let's um let's start
from scratch here just a quick overview
this is kind of what let's see let's see
let's pop this up into here this is kind
of what we're looking at this is a
combination of two textures this is our
cast iron texture here and this is our
rust texture here and it's being
combined via a couple noise Maps through
some multiply and add nodes here jamming
keys I got you
we're gonna figure this one out together
so bear with me all right
the first thing is probably I don't know
let's uh let's make a new scene let's
just start from scratch I'm gonna try
not to reference our original kind of
texture the original set up I'm just
gonna go right off the top of the head
here and try and make this a thing okay
let's do this okay so um I'll just for
the sake of this let's just make a I
don't know I'll make a tube or something
like this and we'll just bring this down
get up just basically just make
something to put our texture onto this
is totally fine now we have no HDRI
environment so it's our scene looks very
plain all right if I were to take a
glossy material which is what we're
gonna start with okay we'll make a
glossy material you can do that by going
up to materials right here making an
octane glossy material you can also hit
shift C in cinema 4d and type in glossy
and you got your octane glossy material
I know my head's covering it but it's
down here on the bottom left I'm just
gonna drag it and apply it to the ring
and nothing really looks like it's
happening here because again we don't
have an a HDRI environment so I'm gonna
make one here we'll make an octane sky
we'll go in here and I'm gonna load one
of my custom oh snap I'm gonna load
that's for later that's for later I'm
gonna load one of my custom HDR eyes so
let's see here let's do the personal
warzone putting together like a little
warzone pack let's try the a plane
destroyed fuselage alright we'll get out
of the Aces linear space and you can see
that we're inside of a destroyed plane
fuselage here okay cool
so this is already looking better
because we want we definitely want a
texture or I'm sorry in an HDR
environment so we even see what our
highlights are looking like all that
good stuff and let's actually take the
tube and like give it a little fill it
here
my radius or segments ten radius to
maybe even one just a little something
okay so we're working with something now
the if I were to pull up that reference
image let's get that reference image
going again
the cast iron one and let's start with
just the normal cast iron all right
right here and I'm actually going to
load this into pure ref pf' is a really
nice program that allows you to
reference images and it's cool because
it always stays on top no matter which
window you have open so let's open this
let's see one moment guys so I just drag
this in
cast iron reference and drag that in and
they will also drag in the like rusty
one too alright so we want to create
this texture this cast iron kind of vibe
right here so the first thing I'm gonna
do maybe this HT re map isn't the best
one let's get something a bit more on
like the the bright side um let's just
do battlefield sunny and that is super
sunny and really contrast the one thing
I do is I actually I'll click the image
here and under color profile just set
that to linear and that's going to kind
of normalize things a little bit for all
of us cool alright so let's see this is
definitely a dark kind of texture so
let's open up our node viewer in octane
and we'll go view frame all and that
should get us right here now we are in
node view right now okay we have our
material right here and there's a bunch
of different slots where we can plug in
different numbers and different images
and all that good stuff and over to the
right here we have our attributes and we
can tweak those things right here so the
first thing I'm probably gonna do is set
the diffuse probably to a darker Brown
so I'm just gonna go in here and kind of
like bring this down come up here and
you can actually sample with this
dropper you can sample this image there
so I'm just gonna pick that color we can
always tweak things later Christian
thank you thank you for the super chat
always hit me with that kombucha thank
you I got some in the fridge I'm gonna
grab it probably once we finish this
texture so thank you sir
I appreciate you ok so obviously right
now this is way too glossy right we can
it looks like an iPhone screen we can
see the reflections perfectly and we
want that if we look at our reference
here we can see that it's certainly not
a mirror okay it's broken up it's
reflective but it's not super sharp so
what we're gonna do is we'll go to
roughness and notice here when I slide
this slider up it disperses our
reflections now it looks more of like a
it's getting closer to a mat kind of
look but it's still reflective it's very
important it's still reflective again we
can edit all this stuff later okay but
let's just work it in so I'm gonna go
like point one five so we can still see
some reflections let's see let's see all
right so next the most obvious thing to
me is the bump channel here you can see
that it's a very fine kind of bump and
it's pretty uniform throughout the
entire thing so it actually gives me
hope here that it'll be pretty easy we
might be able to make this from one or
two noise Maps okay now so over here on
the Left we have a bunch of different
tools that we can pop out and they're
all they're all called nodes right we
want to pop one of these things out
specifically a noise node right here so
I'm just gonna click and drag boom and
now we have a noise node so I can put
this anywhere I want I can take it from
the top right here and connect it to the
diffuse and now the noise map this noise
node is our diffuse right it's our color
we don't want that but we can put it
into the bump right and that's that's
kind of what we want but obviously now
the the projection is off the projection
it just doesn't look right
so how do we fix that it's very simple
go ahead and click your noise node and
go to projection click
right here projection and automatically
it's going to apply this projection node
to your noise node which is again piped
into the bump channel for this material
now we want to clean up the way this
noise node is wrapped around our image
so it's a lot easier for me to see if I
right click the noise node and I got a
solo node then we can really see what's
going on and it's still a little
difficult because it's not as
contrasting so in the noise node I'm
gonna take the contrast to just 100 so I
can really see what's going on
two things I notice one it's stretched
and smeared across this whole thing
second there's a seam right there so
let's take care of both of those things
in one fell swoop
okay so texture projection selected we
have texture projection set to mesh UV
let's change that usually I changed it
to box and you'll say a it's a it
actually looks kind of right now but
you'll still notice there's a seam along
this edge and right here with noise maps
specifically I've found that XYZ to uvw
works flawlessly if you notice here
there are no seams and everything is
just kind of all perfect right so that's
just messing with the texture projection
alright and you'll find that also on the
left here right here transform and
projection those are two nodes that we
can use now there's a whole lot here and
there's definitely like a handful that I
always use I'd say starting from the top
you know these are all just your
materials so you can pull out just full
materials but I usually just have
buttons for those if we go down image
texture that will just you know it'll
it'll be looking for an image on your
computer right you click that it's gonna
look for an image but I just drag and
drop the image from my browser into here
so that does it automatically sometimes
I use RGB spectrum we'll probably be
using that for the rust float I'll use
this this is just the number so this you
can pipe this float texture into a
couple of these different channels and
it's basically a number from zero to one
and you can go beyond one but it's just
a way to you know have an integer have a
number that correlates to a certain
setting so I'll use those all the time I
don't really use anything else up here I
don't use any of this OSL stuff to be
honest with you I don't even what they
are transform and projection those I'm
using all the time
but again if you click your image you
can it has buttons for those right going
on a little further I always use dirt
and I always use fall-off I always use a
noise and that's that's about what I use
from this from the green little tree
here there's a lot from the little red
one that I use I use color correction a
lot I use gradient a lot in gradient is
like levels I'll use invert and I'll use
mix multiply add subtract I'll use all
of those as a way to combine certain
images or certain noises and we'll be
doing a lot of that displacement I use a
lot and some of the stuff I use down
here as well so back to it alright we
have successfully wrapped this noise
around our tube here but this bump is
obviously way too big if I unsolo this
it it doesn't look right at all it looks
like it looks like an interior wall or
something you know that texture on the
wall used to have that as a kid so what
we want to do is actually scale it way
down and we want to take the contrast
down let's go contrast five for now and
you can already see it's kind of getting
that vibe you know it's pushing and
pulling like bump bump is a cheat way of
adding detail there's not actual detail
in the geometry which is good because we
save on a lot of a lot of RAM and memory
so let's scale this down you can scale
it down from the texture projection but
I like to just leave the texture
projection node as just that because
I'll pipe this into a bunch of different
things
so I'm just gonna leave that but I'll
click the noise and I'll click the UVW
transform button
and that's going to add our transform
node and the transform node node is what
I'm gonna use to scale down our texture
okay
and let's just get a sense of scale here
let's figure out how big this thing is
if I were to make a figure right we know
that you know it's about as it's pretty
big it's a pretty big tube there so
let's scale this down let's scale the
tube down I'm hitting t for scale and
I'm just gonna make it just like right
between his feet here well delete the
fit yeah I will delete the figure then
we'll zoom in here so now we know the
scale of this thing right so now we can
better determine how far we need to go
with with the scale so I'll take the
transform then we'll scale it down
[Music]
maybe even more so it's point o2 right
now let's try 0.015 so right now this
looks like scales okay it's it's too
intense and I think it's too uniform so
what I'm gonna do here under noise we
can actually change Pearl and we can
change it to turbulence and it's gonna
kind of switch up the if I again
right-click solo node you can change
when I you can see when I change the
type it's gonna it's gonna change the
way the different kind of noise modes
and if you guys want a whole bunch of
different noise modes you can actually
scroll down here and use the built-in
cinema 4d noise and put that into the
bump and you're gonna have a lot more
options but for the sake of this
tutorial I'm just gonna keep it simple
let me use the the octane bump map here
so let's zoom in let's zoom in alright
so I still think it's a little intense
so I'm gonna take the contrast down to
like 2.5 not 25 2.5 and I'll take from
chips will go turbulence let's try
taking the octaves to give you guys an
idea of what the octaves do if I were to
go one on the octave you can see it kind
of doesn't really look nice okay if I go
ten on the octaves it's gonna add more
detail now the Omega kind of breaks
these bigger chunks into smaller chunks
so let's again for the sake of seeing
what we're doing let's take the contrast
of 50 so octaves one it's kind of like a
lower detail situation octaves 10 is
gonna give you a lot more detail which
is good and now the Omega if I set that
to zero that kind of like blurs out the
shape a little bit and then if I take
the Omega up to one that's gonna kind of
like sharpen it really nicely which is
what we want right so I get you a lot of
nice detail I'm gonna right click this
disable the node and you can start to
see
how it's kind of getting closer I think
um let's see what if we take the
contrast to 100 and I'll just render a
region here so let's try contrast back
to 2.5 and now I'm just messing around
okay um let's try to beYOU lence purlins
I think it's a little small so I'll take
it to 0.25 okay and then yeah I've
taking the Omega down a little bit helps
you guys can start to see here how just
tweaking these little numbers and
tweaking the black and white settings on
your noise gets you a very certain style
of bump which is what we're going for
up here now obviously it looks very blue
because of the Sun or because of the sky
let's change that for more of an
interior HDRI so let me find let's see
let me find one that I took this one
works maybe not
yeah let's let's try another one parking
garage day nice yeah this one's cool and
warm inside kind of feel
and let's go ahead and save here
definitely want to save
okay so yeah we can definitely see we're
getting this kind of texture going let's
see if we can add like let's mix another
node together alright and actually
here's a okay before we do that it's
very easy for me to get sidetracked but
before we do that let me just show you
guys a really cool trick so if you want
to say if you want to like take down the
intensity of this bump here but you
really like the shape of the noise you
have instead of taking the noise and
taking the contrast down what you can
actually do is you can use this little
trick where you take up multiply node
and you grab a float node so the
multiply node is just like when you set
a layer to multiply in after-effects or
something right let's pipe the noise
into texture one and we'll pipe the
multiply into the bump and it's gonna
look the same okay and if I compare and
store the render right these images are
the same but when I put this float
texture and it's set to point five by
default put that in it's basically going
to minimize the intensity of that bump
by 0.5 so you can see it's a very subtle
effect but it's just kind of making the
bump a bit more subtle if I were to take
this float texture to zero that's gonna
be zero bump right so it's just kind of
a slider on how much bump you want now
you can also go the opposite direction
this is a good way to beef up certain
certain textures is you can take that to
like say a five and it's gonna just be
like you know it's gonna add a lot more
crunch and clarity but in this case it's
such a small thing it's such a small
noise map I think we're good just as is
I'm gonna delete that I just want to
show you guys something pretty sweet I
will probably be using that a little bit
later but let's take another look at our
reference we always want to go back to
the reference here you can kind of see
how like there's pock marks taken out of
this there's these like little holes
chipped away in the
thing and I want to kind of combine that
with with this noise map as well so what
we can do let me see if I can actually
pull up another image here one day I
will learn
okay here we go yeah you kind of had
these like chunks taken out from this
thing so yeah let's try grabbing our
noise I'm gonna hold ctrl drag it's
gonna duplicate it alright and then
let's pipe the texture projection and
the transform into this noise as well
and I'm gonna pipe this into the bump so
we know this first bump is good we just
made that let's make a second one where
there's like holes getting taken away
into our texture so let's um actually
change this the chips alright and we'll
right-click it solo it so we see what
we're doing and let's take the contrast
to a hundred and working the gamma is
actually really nice too because that
kind of like changes the exposure of the
noise map and we'll see what that's
doing it dang that looks really nice
that looks super cool yeah you guys can
see how that's really making a
difference there
let's take uhm man that's yeah that's
awesome let's work the yeah there you go
you can see these chips getting taken
out that's so cool these deep grooves
you know um I'm wondering here let's go
let's take the transform let's control
drag the transform and we'll pipe that
into this this node here so the
projection is cool we can we can pipe
the projection into all the different
noise masks we're making but each noise
map might need its own transform that's
why I'm not transforming it from the
texture projection okay so let's see
let's just kind of scale it down this
ticket to 0.15 let's try 0.05 and yeah
there we really get those
like chips and if i zoom in here it
might actually be pushing them up now
they're getting taken down but it look
kind of looks like they're getting
pushed up too it's it's a little intense
so I'm probably going to take the
contrast on that and also that they're
like five
but honestly the high-contrast kind of
helps with I think if we go back here
the high contrast I think it helps out
and let's just take the gamma like way
up and see the black should be getting
pushed down yeah
we can also invert it and that's really
nice actually you can see the holes
getting chipped away in that you can see
anything black is getting push down
anything white is staying so we want to
combine these we want to combine this
texture all right if I store the render
buffer we want to combine that bump with
this bump together right so how do we do
that
a couple different ways you can do that
you can use a mixed a mixed texture or
I'm sorry a mixed node and that's just
looking for texture one which is the
first bump texture two which is the
holes and that goes into bump and that's
just going to blend them 5050 and that
actually might just work for what we're
doing right you can still see these
holes being pushed down and if we go to
this noise we can probably yeah I guess
you can't really increase the intensity
beyond pure black and white which is
kind of already what it is but what you
could do is maybe take this noise this
first bump and kind of chill it out
we'll take the contrast to one or maybe
even two and then do that multiply float
trick so we'll grab multiply and we'll
just drag it right in there and we'll
grab the float and we want to just kind
of bump it up a little bit so for
instead of 0.5 we'll take it to two and
it's gonna kind of beef up that texture
a little bit and you can push and pull
these values all day long but I think at
the end of the day you guys get the idea
also just quick tip here you can see how
this is super white and getting blown
out if I put a an octane camera tag on
my camera and I go to camera imagery
let's check this box there's a little
highlight compression slider and notice
this highlight here if it's white
you know if I enable the render render
buffer and I slide this up
it's gonna save those highlights and you
can see the difference right here so I
use that a lot it's a really really nice
one okay so we kind of have this cast
iron effect here just from using to
noise Maps that's it our diffuse channel
is set to kind of like that darkish
brown color and I just use this
eyedropper and clicked on here you can
also find your own color if you want to
desaturate that a little bit more and
just make it kind of a black technically
it's like a it's a totally dark kind of
color here I think we can maybe add a
little bit of color in it you know like
a like a dark brown or something that
works too but always I think the most
important thing here is reference you
guys want to reference the actual
textures when you go out on a walk take
some pictures and try and think how
would I create that in post you know and
that's that's what we're doing right now
you guys falling along so far we're
gonna make the rust texture next and
then we're actually doing some really
cool stuff to combine them together to
get this like multi-leveled you know
kind of pattern here where it gets dark
on the inside light on the outside all
that good stuff and yeah you guys are
awesome you guys are really doing a good
job in the in the chat here helping each
other out it means a lot
Oh winbush what's up dude hey man I was
just shouting you out I was telling
about your unreal tutorials that I'm
gonna be learning from you that's
awesome you're here
sweet heck yeah
why do I use a bump over a normal
honestly it's because I don't know how
to make my own normal image here if I
were to take this multiply and put it
into normal because normal is looking
for the AC it looks all jacked up
normal is looking for an image that
looks like let's see I should be able to
pull something up really quick normal is
looking for an image that looks like
this it's actually a color image and
it's pushing and pulling points in four
directions based on the color
you know there's green there's magenta
there's blue and like maybe yellow or
somewhere orange and honestly I don't
know how I don't know if octane has
something to like the noise equivalent
of a normal map maybe it does but I'm
just not sure you know I'm just not sure
I'm just I'm just I'm just trying to
tell you guys the info that I know and I
don't know all the answers says for sure
so okay we got this little cast iron
effect here's looking super cool all
right we can tweak this all you want but
let's make this rust texture okay so I'm
gonna start I'm just going to name this
down here I know you can't see I'm just
double clicking there we go I'm gonna
double click this I'm gonna just call
this cast iron base and I'm just gonna
start and I'm just gonna make a diffuse
material and octane diffuse material
boom all right we're in
alright let's slide me back over okay
so we're starting from scratch again
we're gonna make this orange kind of
rusty material here let's go ahead and
name this rust cool save our progress
now let's see here let's see here um
okay first thing I'm gonna do is apply
the rust to the tube
all right let's rerender our scene and
we're starting with this okay
let's give our our camera a little bit
of depth of field just to make things
look kind of nice I'll choose where it's
focusing
sweet let's go two and three
get that anamorphic look yeah you see
these you see these highlights in the
background if you say your aperture
aspect ratio - - and your aperture edge
- three it's gonna give you that
anamorphic effect which looks always
like super nice all right
first things first let's change the
color I'm going to go to the diffuse tab
here I'll grab the color picker and
let's just grab the orange right here
alright so already I think we can
combine these two materials to kind of
get an effect that looks like this but
let me just think about this for a
second because there's different parts
of this there's that like clear kind of
pale orange on the outside of all this
like right in here and then it gets to a
more saturated Orange a brighter orange
and on the inside on the deepest parts
is that like burnt kind of red Brown
rusty kind of bit so we how are we gonna
do this let's think about this for a
second I'm wondering if all of this is
in the way we combine the materials
hmm how would I do this how would I do
this
okay let's grab a noise node and let's
pipe it into the diffuse channel again
the the mapping is off so I'm going to
click projection I'm also going to give
it transform will set the projection to
XYZ to UVW and I'm going to set the
contrast to 100 so we can see what we're
doing
transform point I don't know Oh point
one 0.02 all right cool let's get rid of
the depth of field it's not helping us
currently currently not helping us come
on yeah get get all right there we go so
we kind of want to use this noise map
here and where there's these black parts
we want to kind of chip into those with
different colors so let's set the
contrast to 25 or even I don't know 10
that way we have a bit more you know
gray values to work with it's not just
black and white now the easiest way to
color this thing is with a gradient so
I'm gonna go down here grab the gradient
and just pipe that in to the noise right
now it looks the same because it's
automatic just set to black and white by
default but anything that is white boy
okay anything that's white will set to
orange alright so I'm gonna use the
color picker I'm gonna grab there's pale
orange because that's the outermost
color we'll hit okay and you can see
that it's as pale as orange now and just
for the sake of this I'm going to
brighten this up and the next color in
is more of a like a
brighter orange so I'm gonna make a new
little pip there double-click go in grab
the color picker and I'm gonna go I'm
gonna find just like the most saturated
orange I can find BAM like right in
there and I'm just gonna crank it to a
really saturated Orange you can see now
that it's kind of getting us that vibe
next I think there's a fourth one
or there's a third one I'll grab the
color picker and I'm seeing here it
might be a little hard to see but this
is like a British more saturated Orange
on the on the inside just one step in
it's kind of a bit more towards that
pale colour all right so I'm head up a
and then finally on the inner most I
mean I guess it goes another layer but
on the inner most will select a color
picker again I'm gonna go that dark
red-brown and this is really tiny so I
need to get in there and maybe let's see
if we can like find a spot like here
that's pretty dark um
this is nice this dark dark red-brown
right here boom head okay
and then finally on the inner most it's
set to like just basically like a dark
really dark brown so this looks gross
this looks like some nasty like hot
cheeto madness right now um but here's
the plan here's the plan we're gonna mix
these two textures together okay and I'm
probably gonna grab the same bump map
let's actually let's let's do that yeah
let's do that let's go to the cast iron
that we made let's grab this whole tree
right here this bump I'm gonna hit ctrl
C let's go back to our rust and I'm
gonna hit control V and that should
paste everything and actually if you
right-click it and go auto arrange
selected nothing will happen
okay here we go yeah you'll right click
it in herbs
for you all right so I'm gonna pipe that
into the bump and you'll see that it
doesn't really look like it's doing much
because it's not really reflecting
anything and it's hard to see without
reflections or light values but it's
doing a little something but I know that
this rust is caked on top of this cast
iron if the cast iron bump is set to one
or let's say it's just set to 100 it's
maxed out the bump on this this rust
here is probably a lot lower since it's
caked on top and it's kind of smoothed
out it's probably like 25% of the bump
of this so if this float texture and
that's a good thing about this multiply
float trick if I go to the float texture
if this float is 0.5 I want to set it to
a quarter of that so I can just honestly
hit times 0.25 and that'll it'll do the
math for you so it's a bit more smooth
that you know
so now what we want to do is combine
this rust with our cast iron alright and
this is where everything comes together
and it looks really really nice okay so
I'm gonna make a mix material over here
I have a button for it you can also go
to materials and make a mix material or
again hit shift C and type mix and then
there you go if your mix material so
let's make one of those okay and let's
go in to the mix material and right now
it's just it's nothing it's looking for
two materials to mix together and it's
using a flow texture set to 0.5 for the
amount so it's basically going to just
be like if you were in Photoshop you put
two images on top of each other and you
set the top image to 50% opacity that's
that's the way it's blending together
it's gonna look like but but you guys
will see what I'm doing a couple
different ways to apply this um let's
just kind of bring this down with the
mixed material select and you can see
here material 1 material - I'm gonna
drag rust in the material 1 cast iron
into material 2 and now we have a mess
so find the original fine find that
mixed material here just put it off to
the side and let me actually give us
some space here
okay so this mix material is what
everything is coming down to it's coming
down to this all right
and that's actually just we should be
able to update this I don't know why
those materials aren't piped in anyway
this cast iron weird what what
that's super weird why is it okay hold
on that might just be an octane glitch
I'm gonna just try and apply this tube
and it looks like it's working properly
and let's go into the mix material the
note editor and yeah okay it's working
now so we just want to make sense of all
this let's take the cast iron base right
click it and auto arrange selected will
right-click it again and we'll select
the hierarchy so now we have everything
that is the cast iron base with you know
the all the stuff going into the bump
map and we'll do the same for the rust
so I'll right-click the rest we will
auto arrange selected right click it
again select hierarchy boom
that's the rust alright and it's all
going being combined together through
this mix material ok now we want to
combine it together in a special way
we're going to use some noise maps to do
that right so this is all physically
based that means like you can scale it
up you can you can you can adjust and
edit all these settings and it's just
gonna work no matter what which is great
that's amazing
so let's take the flow texture we're
gonna believe it we don't we don't even
need it and let's let's bring this image
back up alright so we can see what's
going on and right now it looks like
some nasty like burnt skin or if you
were made of Cheetos and then you got
burnt like you would look like this or
it looks like some pizza we don't want
that we want it to look like our cast
iron reference like this right - the
water droplets okay we're going for this
vibe right here and I'm also noticing
some cool specular stuff going on here
so I might and I might work back and
just add that at the end but let's
combine these together to get this look
okay
so again we want to combine this in a
very particular way so we have this
noise map in our roughness or I'm sorry
in our rust texture it's the
specifically the diffuse that is giving
us these these colors that are laid out
in a very specific way and we're going
to want to kind of basically chip away
at this texture at this rust texture to
reveal the cast iron underneath okay
so we kind of we want to use the same
noise map that is making up this rust
texture because if we were to use any
one just any old noise map I'll show you
guys the difference here let's go up
here I'm going to right click the
gradient will select the hierarchy I'll
bring this up this is going to be the
the basis of how we combine these two
textures alright so I'm gonna take this
I'm actually just gonna copy it and
paste it down here and here let me show
you guys what I mean so right now if I
were to right click the gradient will
solo it okay this pale inner most and
let's let's just make this as let's
let's just pipe this in sorry guys I'm
kind of going here we go this is like
pale most inner most part of the rust I
want that to just be white actually this
whole image needs to be black and white
all right so I think we can just take a
color correction node and pipe it in
between the gradient in the actual
texture itself and then we can probably
if we solo it set the saturation to zero
and I don't know if that's doing
anything it's probably like what okay
but here yeah this is actually kind of
working already you guys can see that
we're using this noise map to reveal the
rust or the cast iron underneath but
it's very sharp and there's too much of
it there's a whole lot of it we only
want the rust to be where there would be
water right so that would just kind of
be on the tops and maybe on the edge
right here but it's not going to be
really too much on the sides and it's
not really gonna be on the bottom at all
it's just kind of be on the gonna be on
the top where the water hits and to
prove that to you guys let's go and
navigate to the image I'm pretty sure
there's a way to do this here image all
good I'll just pull it up and I'll pull
up another reference image for you guys
to show that the rust only hits where
the water is is hitting this image so
it's on the bottom it's kind of on the
edges where precipitation builds up but
it's not on the sides here you know it's
not on the nozzle just where the water
hits so to do that what I'm doing to
actually do that is use a fall-off node
which is really cool it's a really
really cool node that allows you to do
some really cool tricks so let's go into
our mix material we'll go to our node
editor and well adjust the amount in a
second but let's just get that fall-off
node going real quick so let's go fall
off let's drag the fall-off out and
let's pipe the fall-off in to the amount
just so we can again see what we're
doing
and by default it's not doing what we
want it's kind of hitting the edges here
but if we click fall-off and by default
it's set to normal versus IRA we want to
go normal versus is it 180 or is it 90
so 90 gets the edges like that let's
right-click it solo it to see what's
going on 180 I feel like is what we want
um but that's not working I think it's
actually doing the opposite I think it's
hitting the bottom yeah it's hitting the
bottom we want to say at the top so I
believe could we just go negative one
there you go
and it's just hitting the top now again
it looks like cheeto dust so we want to
adjust that all right so we want to we
had this fall-off node we'll save that
in a second we'll pipe this gradient
back in and let's just kind of figure
out so yeah there's so many there's a
couple things we need to do I just need
to figure out which one we want to do
first let's to keep things not confusing
let's focus on how this rust texture
there's just too much of it right now we
know that we need to get rid of it on
the sides but let's just focus on the
top and it's getting rid of the darkest
parts we wanted to get rid of the
lightest parts okay so let's think about
this for a second let's right-click the
grading will solo it it's getting rid of
the darkest parts we wanted to get rid
of the lightest parts so what we can do
is simply we can go to the noise maybe
inverting it no inverting it won't work
we can actually add an invert node and
the biggest thing about all the nodes
and stuff is you just need to know what
is out there and yeah we have invert
nodes and now you can see just the
darkest parts
of the rust are visible but we want to
open that up right so that we see that
really nice saturated orange and the
pale orange as well so let's go back in
and figure out how we're gonna do that
okay so under gradient let's just take
the noise and remember how I said the
the gamma is a way to kind of change the
exposure if we adjust the gamma and it's
very touchy if we just the gamma it's
gonna kind of open it up a little bit
make it brighter and I think that's what
we're gonna need to use to reveal yes
some of that orange there so the gamma
is set to 1 by default but let's say we
go one point two five that is basically
gonna give us it's gonna kind of grow
our mask here and show us a little bit
more of that image and now we get the
bright orange on the inside I think we
can take the Omega and we can go to like
0.8 and that's gonna give us a bit more
detail that you see in here and we can
also adjust our colors if we go up to
the rust texture and we go to the
gradient we can start moving these
colors around and giving it a bit more
saturation this dark brown can be set to
more of a darker color
yeah something like that
so there's too much of it we want to
kind of chip away at it so I think if we
adjust the let's see if we adjust the
noise gamma in the actual diffuse I
think let's change that to like point
two or maybe two
let's try one point five I don't think
that's how we're gonna do I think it
needs to actually come from down here
we're gonna take this noise we'll go one
point five yeah we need to figure out a
way let's see is it it's not
so you can see how by working the gamma
we can open that up to the more pale
noise or the more pale rust then I'm
using contrast to clip it if I go full
contrast it's gonna be really intense
but I want to find that line where just
kind of falls off into the actual rust
so there's again there's too much of it
we just need to figure out the best way
of reducing that so I'm gonna save and
think about this
and I think it definitely has to do with
let's see if I take this gradient and I
just set all of these two gray values
yeah it's gonna give us the same thing
hmm what if I take the gradient and what
if I just replace the gradient with a
default one
what if we adjust the the texture the
transform here so instead of 0.02 will
go like 0.1 we have to adjust it up here
too so they should actually have the
same transform tied to both of these so
we'll set this to like 0.1 but that's
obviously there's obviously too much so
we'll go point oh five maybe
and one thing let's see one thing we can
do let's see how are we gonna reduce
this that's that's my biggest thing here
and again I feel like it's all in the
gamma so if I set this gamma to point 2
and this gam at a point - that takes it
away completely if I go gamma 0.8 and
0.8 because remember these are tied
together let's try again 1 + 1 right
that gives us that look
let's try point 9 and point 9 that's
kind of working it back now this gamma
that is combining our two materials
together it needs to be I believe a lot
a little bit larger than the original
because that's the way we're getting
those extra colors right so if we set
this gamma to 0.9 and this gamma to 0.8
then we should start chipping away at
our rust and
that is actually looking a little bit
nicer to me it's now we need if we give
some color correction we can actually
start to get some of these orange values
to be a bit more saturated so if we go
to the camera imager on our camera tab
here will go saturation we can just
boost that to like yeah that looks gross
1.2 or something to get a get us a bit
more of that color we can also throw
like a lot on here
I know Kodachrome 25 is a real nice one
you can use porta you know and just just
play with these these values a whole
bunch and the camera imager is super fun
I like it a lot we can adjust the
exposure
and you know it's just pushing and
pulling these values until you feel
content with everything
let's try gamma 1 and point 9 actually
what happens if we go 0.5 that doesn't
look right
that's not bad so you just need to make
sure that the gamma on your noise that
is combining your two materials together
is a little bit higher than the one that
is controlling the diffuse and again
that's because they're tied together and
you you basically want to allow that
diffuse room to come in so this is our
this is our kind of layer with all of
our rust here and again let's figure out
how we can apply that fall-off map to
just have it so that the rust is on the
top versus the sides so let's get a bit
more of an exaggerated example so I'll
set my gamma 1 and 0.9 right so we have
these this rust here and it's on the
sides we don't want that so what we'll
do is we're gonna use our fall-off map
to make sure it's just hitting the top
right so this fall-off map right here if
we pipe that into the amount you can
really see that it's just allowing the
stuff on the top to come through but
that's not what we want because again
that looks like lava or pizza or
something we want to just have this bit
on the top so I think what we need to do
is use an add node to combine these two
together so I'm gonna go to add I'll
drag this out I'll drag the fall-off in
to texture 1 and our are our noise tree
here into texture 2 and we'll put that
into the amount and hopefully it'll work
okay totally doesn't work let's try a
multiply node boom multiply and
basically what we're doing if I'm hard
to explain this here if I were to
right-click and solo this um what's the
best way to show this because right now
it's coming off as orange so I think
this is supposed to be white and
everything else is black and then for
this other image this is white and
everything else is black so we want man
this is really hard to explain um yeah
let me just see this works apologies
guys I know I should be explaining this
but yes there you can see it it worked
it kept a rust layer with all the holes
that are you know peeking through to the
actual cast iron but it also took away
all the all the stuff on the side so if
I were to disable the solo there you can
see that it is actually working properly
how we want it to now if you want I
think there's another cool thing you can
do where you actually like chip away at
the rust a little bit more with another
noise map or a noise node so I'll drag a
noise no doubt will give it the texture
of the projection and sometimes it
doesn't it doesn't work so I'll just put
these manually the projection will come
out this way boom and we'll set that
again to XYZ VW and we'll pipe that into
the amount and we'll right-click it and
solo it so we can see we're doing will
set contrast to hundreds and you see
we're doing it's way too big let's
disable solo we'll set it to go to
transform we'll set that to like 0.1
yeah that I think that works we'll go to
the noise will set the noise octaves to
10 and the Omega 1 so it's breaking it
up in a pretty interesting way I think
we can go maybe Omega 0.8 yeah
Omega 1 looks nice and let's maybe
change that to I don't think turbulence
works I think purlins is nice we can
take the gamma
up a little bit so it's just kind of
like half and half there that looks
pretty nice so what we're going to do is
we're going to use this node this black
and white node here to reveal certain
parts of
this texture setup we have well Oh
bear with me yeah it's okay yeah we want
to chip away at this so it's like this
is a hundred percent we have this rust
texture across the board here we want to
kind of chip away at that a little bit
with this noise map that we set up so I
believe this is when we use add so I'm
going to bring an ad out we'll go pipe
that into texture to this multiply goes
in texture one and now hopefully we
should see if this works the edges here
will stay the same and we'll just be
chipping away at the rust that's up here
let's see moment of truth totally didn't
work let's try a subtract node
I thought ad was gonna work I mean I
only actually tries to switching these
around switching around the placement
and refresh the scene just just to make
sure okay yeah that doesn't work and I
it's it's either a multiply add or
subtract and it depends on what is black
and what is white it can be a bit
confusing sometimes so I'll just give
these a shot I try to add again come on
and it's probably multiply it's usually
always multiply okay let's try to
multiply again last chance
and I believe that is working
let's try flipping around these slots
here and when we adjust this noise if I
set the gamma to zero it should be
default if I set the gamma to like 100
there should be nothing so maybe setting
it to 1 I think it's taking away too
much it's taking away too much so just
got to be very subtle with it
and we'll go back to linear just so we
can see a bit more of what's going on
and I think it again it's taking away
too much so I'm just gonna go back to
the original there and yeah that's
basically your your Russ material I'll
switch out the HDR eyes you can see it
in another lighting scenario there you
go
yeah gross why did it do that yes that's
the idea you know you can apply this to
anything you want and it's just gonna
work like an oil tank or something set
this to 100 and again we did mmm create
this material from the standpoint of
like a smaller object so it's only gonna
really work when you like zoom in if you
want it on something huge you might have
to change the transform on those on
those uh those noise maps but let's take
like now let's take a sphere here scale
it down we'll set it to 100 and we'll
just chop the top of it off
like this we go.you I to invert
selection I'll select all those polygons
on the sphere control a and then I'll
hit what is it mt4 extrude and I'll make
sure create caps is on so that'll give
it some thickness and then I'll hit
let's see e for scale and I'll just
bring that down so this is flat up here
and then we can even give it some bevel
so I'll hold shift and give it a little
bit of bevel it's way too intense we'll
set the offset the point 1 even that is
too intense so we'll set that to 0.02
and we'll set subdivisions to like 3
maybe it's point O 3 0.035 and then
we'll apply the material to that and
there you go you have like a a rusty old
pop
right and we can we can kind of you can
see the rust down there as it collects
at the bottom and it's on the edges here
looking nice so yeah you guys can push
and pull those numbers all around to get
the desired effect that desired scale
you can tweak the colors all that cool
stuff and you saw how that you can
create this from scratch with just noise
now if you guys are still hanging out
let's let's take three minutes or so to
take a break and just catch up and then
we'll make that dirty rain texture using
similar techniques but I also think it's
a it's a little bit different it's
similar in the sense that like we're
gonna be taking that rain map and we'll
actually let's all download that right
now if you guys are following along
let's go to Cornelius Dominic's website
that's Cornelius town right calm you
guys can see it here boom Cornelius
Tamra calm and for those of you who just
want a link I think that's the one if
you go to tutorials and you scroll down
right here 8 k raindrop displacement
this is the only raindrop displacement
texture I know of on the Internet it's
one of the best and it actually gives me
an idea or it reminds me of an idea I so
like you guys know I'm working on an on
a custom HDRI tutorial it's coming along
it's just taking a lot of work I don't
have much time to work on it that's why
things along but I'd like to do another
one as well I'd like to do a
displacement tutorial and talk to you
guys about the surface in or not
displacement I'm sorry you guys you know
what I'm talking all straight for like
two hours I start to lose my mind a
surface imperfection tutorial ok and I'm
gonna break down all the different
surface imperfections that you see in
real life and I want to actually make my
own surface imperfections with you guys
and we'll make a cool rain one all right
we can make some finger prints we can
make grunge we can do a scratch one and
I'm actually gonna like you know set it
up like I'm gonna get a plane of a
window plane and put water all over it
and have a black backdrop and light it
and take a picture and get a real nice
nice image and go into Photoshop and
tweak those and we'll learn how to make
our own surface imperfections I think
that'll be super fun we'll bust out some
paint we'll get some fingerprints on a
white canvas kind of thing so that
that's later that's down the line but
yeah if you guys are following along
download this rain raindrop displacement
map because we're about to use it all
right how's everybody doing guys we got
thumbs up thumbs up all around and
winbush glad you're still here man it's
cool for you to hang out
yeah texturing is intense man it's like
there's just a lot that goes into it
it's my favorite though I love spending
a lot of time getting something to look
nice because at the end of the day like
making things photo real and putting
them into actual you know footage that's
that's what I do it's what I've been
doing for since I started the effects so
yeah I love it a lot and again I really
want to learn unreal because you can get
some photo real results with that
program and I want to be able to create
photo real environments like you guys
see all over you know from quick soul
and stuff that's that that's the goal
that's the dream for me this year
like I want at the end of this year I
won't be able to create something
awesome in unreal
sweet why okay so this is a question I
get sometimes why I have two versions of
After Effects
there is a plugin for this two plugin
called real steady and it is the best
camera stabilization plug-in that that
there is personally that's what I
believe
the they only have it for 2014 After
Effects so that's why I have that maybe
they updated it and they have you know
hopefully they've updated it at this
point but that's why I have two versions
of After Effects cuz it's the only one
it's the only one that has it all right
guys let's hop into this second and
final texture here okay it's the rain
this rain texture dirty rain how do we
do it
okay let's start with um let's just hide
the sphere and let's change out our HDRI
alright and this time I don't have a
reference image I know there's there was
one around but I don't have it with me
alright let's open up this warzone HDRI
pack I want to release say a bunch of
war zone HDR eyes for you guys I think
that'd be really cool right now I only
have six or seven but I'd love to get
like thirty solid ones and like release
it on Gumroad for like five bucks or
something let's let's do the destroyed
helicopter the interior of a destroyed
helicopter cool yeah we're looking
around here that's that's fun alright so
let's just make a sphere real quick I'll
scale it down
we'll give it some segments and yeah
that's not really looking like anything
at all okay because it needs textures
that's what we're doing so I'm gonna
make another glossy texture an octane
glossy texture okay
I'll drag and drop and you can see here
based on these reflections you know we
we're getting some reflections which is
exactly what we want when you have a wet
kind of material so let's see here I'm
not gonna go into a car shader because
that's pretty advanced but what I will
do is talk about how to get this dirty
rain effect and just so we know it's
working I'm gonna make the sphere
editable I'm gonna hit ul for a ring
selection I'm gonna select that that and
I'm a gross selection with you why I'll
hit MT for extrude and we'll just
extrude that out so we're kind of making
this like almost Saturn looking kind of
deal here and I'll just kind of scrunch
this down a little bit okay the reason I
do this is because I want to show you
guys how we can get the water to collect
in the corners and it gets a bit dirtier
in the corners right if we reference our
original image that I had for you guys
let me see if I can pull it up real
quick
yep right here you can see that in the
corners things get a little bit darker a
little dirtier here in the corners and
then it's a bit hard to see in this
image wait way to render out a test
image that doesn't really give the
example but in the rain map you can see
that the inside of the rain holds more
dirt than the outside so yeah we'll be
breaking that down all right so let's
just bevel these edges I always like to
hold shift and drop a bevel modifier on
there
offset 0.02 let's try 0.1 and we'll work
let's see let's see we'll work this
slider until use angle yeah I want to
use the angle but here let's see if
let's see if that works I want to get
that inside angle and I think it's just
like a little too intense come on point
one five three and heck I'm gonna go to
edge mode ul for loop selection why it's
not working
ring is that or is that a ring selection
you be now it should be ul oh it's
because it's not optimized go to
segments control a hit you oh it's gonna
optimize it and then it should still not
working geez edges ul loop selection why
let's try another trick polygons ul loop
selection it's like that one hold ctrl
switch two edges in fact switch hold
ctrl switch two points deselect the top
group of points holding ctrl getting rid
of those holding ctrl again go to edges
now we have that edge selected so with
that select that I'm at ul
hold shift get that one we're gonna set
the selection you can go to select set
selection it's gonna make a little
selection edge selection tag we'll go to
our bevel we will drag that into
selection and go it should be optimized
I don't know why it's doing that
Bevell should be MW I'm sorry ms hmm you
oh I know that optimizes things but I
don't know why that isn't working
do you guys have any pointers for me I
did the caps on extrude oh I see I see I
see I see okay
what on earth
okay how about we just start from the
top here guys apologies well boom this
shouldn't oh yeah I kind of suck at
certain aspects of this one to go you
wide grow MW and I'm sorry M T alright
so let's extrude it what what is
happening why is not working
I don't guess I don't know what's
happening anymore I'm gonna just brute
force this we're gonna go with a tube
okay and we're just gonna brute force it
we're gonna able to fill it that's
totally fine it gets the point across
all right
and that right here will be the model we
apply the texture to all right doesn't
matter at this point just doesn't matter
so we got this glossy material we want
it to look like it was rained on okay so
I think the best way to do that is to
use that that Cornelius Dominic
displacement texture so I'm gonna go
into our node view we'll go view frame
all right
you have our material and usually you
can apply this to either the bump or
that it's placement let's see what works
better
let's get that image going where are you
at rain drop displacement let's drag and
drop that in cool cool and let's put
that in the bump for now and see what
happens
so it looks kind of weird if we zoom in
it's not really doing what we want I
think again the texturing or the
projection and the transform is all off
so let's first fix the projection and
we'll go box and now it looks still
looks weird let's right-click it and
solo it and see what's happening it
needs to be transformed down
let's try point 1 and there you go you
can start to see the effect there so I'm
gonna right click and disable the solo
and then the soloing really helps see
what is going on and what it looks like
now and I don't think bump is the right
place to put this so I'm actually gonna
try displacement so we'll go to this
placement here and we'll add a
displacement node you can also find that
by scrolling down and it's just here on
the left so if we zoom in let's take
this image let's pipe it into this
texture displacement undo the bump and I
think octane is gonna crash oh my
goodness
okay so usually what I do before putting
anything into displacement is I'll just
set my settings so the height will go to
one centimeter mid level we'll set to
0.5 and the level of detail this is an
8k texture I'm gonna go for k4 now this
is craziness
all over the place let's keep bringing
the height down in point one let's take
it out of the bump channel let's
right-click and solo it to see what's
happening let's make sure we're using
the right image I believe so
okay here we go yeah we want to make
sure we're using this actual
displacement one I was using something
else
so this displacement one is actually
gray the gray is like the gray isn't
going anywhere
white is what it gets pushed up okay
when you set your mid level to 0.5 the
gray goes nowhere so let's try that
again
okay let's disable the solo and now it
should look a bit more natural alright
let's take the transform back up let's
go 0.5 and it's kind of hard to see here
but this actually looks pretty nice I
can see that it's it's working and it's
breaking up the the image pretty nicely
you can see these little bits of of
water and stuff so what we want to do is
basically in the diffuse channel use
this texture here that is our diffuse or
that is our displacement right we want
to use that to only put a certain color
in our case like a like a black dirty
color we want to put a certain color
inside of those raindrops so let me show
you guys let's go up here we'll go to an
RGB spectrum at the very top right here
this little blue this little blue bunch
here RGB spectrum we'll bring that out
we want to make sure by default it's
white let's set to black okay and let's
pipe let's see how we can do this we
want to only have let's okay here's what
we'll do
here's what we'll do I'm thinking out
loud so apologies let's control drag
this raindrop material up here so we
have a duplicate transform and
projection should be exactly the same
okay it's very important that they're
exactly the same because
they're working together alright let's
pipe this this placement into the
diffuse channel and see what we're
getting boy
okay so octane is pretty stupid
sometimes there's a glitch here where
you can't adjust the transform of your
displacement it actually but why is it
why is it working
in this case is it only when you have a
diffuse going because oh goodness okay
let me think about this for a second
maybe this does need to be in the bump
channel transform should be 0.1 and I
feel yeah I feel like we still get the
we still get the effect we can chill it
out by using that multiply float trick
so I'm gonna drop drag a multiply in
between the image and the bump channel
and I'll put float into the second
texture here the texture to slot and
we'll just set it it's set to 0.5 by
default which is gonna kind of chill out
that rain a little bit but I think that
looks nice
that's not bad now it's going to work
okay so let's take this rain image
control drag it up pipe in the original
transform and projection nodes
all right and put that into defuse now
we want to crunch this pretty hard so
anything that's gray we want to be black
anything that is light gray we want to
be white okay
so let's first right-click and solo it
and let's just work the gamma to see
what we can do first so I'm looking for
the most contrast I think just cranking
it up to eight probably works and then
I'm going to put in a gradient node here
which is basically levels and we'll sell
that and I'm just gonna take the light
and crank these values together let's
see how far this goes the black is very
finicky okay see that's about as far ooh
that is touchy but basically wherever
there is um white or a light gray that's
where we're going to have actual color
right anywhere where there's black there
will be no color so I'm just really
really trying to be careful here it's so
finicky let me see if just changing the
gamma back to one works for us because
then where was it set to 2.2 by default
yeah let's try again yeah there we go
it's gonna be easier to control there we
go
so this is gonna be how we distribute
our color across the image so let's see
here let's think about this we want the
inside of the rain to be darker than the
paint that it's on
so let's undo that let's take that out
of the fuse think about this for a
second
let's make another let's make a mix
material or a mix node all right so we
take a mix node and let's duplicate our
RGB spectrum let's set it to the color
just white
that's what's point nine point nine
across the board so that is going to be
our base color for our object is
controlled through this RGB spectrum in
texture to texture one this will be our
dirt
that'll be piped into texture one okay
now if I put that into diffuse it should
just be gray because it's mixing them by
half by default but we don't want to mix
them that way we want to mix them with
this dirt map we created this one here
so let's take this and put this into the
amount and hopefully now it's not it's
not doing much
let's try switching these two around
well that's because it's not we need to
put the mix texture into the diffuse
okay so the mixed texture goes into
diffuse and it's the opposite of what we
want now so we want to flip we can we
can either change the colors or we could
just flip these around I think I'll just
switch the order of these and there you
go you can see how we have a dirty rain
texture right so I'm using the actual
rain image okay and the reason we're not
using noise in this case is because this
is a very specific kind of of noise I
don't know of any noise that looks like
rain and this is the only rain image I
know of on the internet that's seamless
and super high-quality so you guys can
start to see how you can get like a
dirty rain texture
with this little trick now the mapping
is a little weird it set the box which
makes it weird if I set it to let's see
let's try setting it to XYZ to UVW I
don't think it's gonna work it usually
yeah it does this weird thing where it
stretches it like that now there might
be something that I'm missing object
space world space I don't know I might
be missing an element here
I know ash Thorpe uses this method a lot
but I don't know if he's doing anything
extra
let's try transforming it I think it
just needs rotation maybe it needs to be
like rotated 90 degrees on one of these
axes here but it's it's still just
looking weird it's always gonna be
looking weird in one direction and I
hadn't found out the answer yeah I don't
know if you guys have any tips for me on
this with spherical work I mean yes
vehicle might work but like you'd want
something that works across the board
for everything but let's try let's try
spherical real quick we'll go texture
projection we'll set that back to zero
we'll try spherical yeah I'd say that
that looks pretty nice I think we need
to transform this up a little bit we'll
try 0.5 but it's still looking weird
it's looking stretched here on this bit
that's a tough one I think it's a
case-by-case situation
try planer try planer just just takes it
away completely
hmm yeah try planners not working unless
I'm doing something wrong or unless it's
like so small I can't even see it let's
just try cranking it to 20 no a hundred
yeah it's not it's not really doing a
thing
I needed an additional node to make it
work can you guys explain to me this tri
planar situation you need the Tri planar
node okay okay oh I see it right here
try plane or node I have never used this
before oh my god it looks complicated
texture try planar node input okay
so it'd be the texture let's try this
let's give this a shot so it's the
texture plot into the Tri planar node
man this might have to be a tutorial
situation here plug the texture into X
and click use single texture plug the
texture into X single texture okay and
then this goes into the I guess I'd go
into the multiply now let's just try
bump yeah it kind of works
so is the triplane er like the last
thing in the sequence
like does it go mixed texture into the
try planer and finally into diffuse or
is tri planar like the first thing that
it goes through because technically this
tri planar would would be here in the
sequence but it took away the dirt
somehow somehow it took away the dirt
so it's a little small what I still just
use this transform to scale things up
but that's not applying to this one up
here yeah that one's big now
oh is that working now I think yeah
we're good I just needed to delete let's
see let's set this to 0.5 it still looks
like it's tearing down here
all right um yeah I'm still seeing like
it feels like it's actually still
tearing but that might be a tutorial for
myself for another time so this is
basically the idea guys let's just see
if we can't get some dirt in the corners
so the way I'm gonna do that is through
a dirt node so let's take the green
chunks here this little lose the green
bit we'll go dirt pipe that into diffuse
to see what's going on by default I can
already see some darkness here I think I
think I can let's take the strength to
ten so we can see what we're doing and
yeah sure enough it's working down here
so what I'll do is we'll use this image
here we'll combine it with this image
here so we want both of these basically
wherever it's white is where the the
dirt is showing up but in this case and
our dirt map it's the opposite so we
want to flip these colors around and I
think the easiest way if we invert this
I don't think it's gonna work yeah
that's gonna get the edges we want the
corners and the best way is probably to
throw in a gradient and to just flip
these colors around and that should do
it for us
yeah so it's just white in the corners
there so this is what we'll be using and
we're going to I believe we want to keep
the white here but we also want to keep
whatever is white in this texture as
well we want to add these together okay
so we're gonna use the add no
well add the dirt and then we'll add the
rain okay we'll pipe that into diffuse
solo it and this is what we want this is
exactly what we want so this is what
will go into the amount right so we'll
take this ad and the ad goes into the
amount
well unsolo it and now you'll see let's
take that out of the diffuse and we just
gotta organize some things here let's
take ad we will auto arrange that
hierarchy select it and just move it
around over here the triplane air will
go into diffuse
huh maybe the gradient let's see um
maybe we flipped the gradient around
again or maybe it wasn't ad maybe it was
WOW weird
because I feel like this is what we want
this is totally what we want anything
white is where there will be dirt that
makes sense to me yeah that look that
makes sense to me
the triplane er is taking it away what
on earth oh I'm gonna do away with these
try planners for a second guys and the
image texture will just give it the
projection again
we'll set at the box transform 0.1 just
for now
these nodes are combination of they're
actually just octane nodes they're not
c4d nodes this is all in octane but
again these these tips can be applied to
you know any program any renderer so
we're close we we just want let's see if
we can actually tweak this dirt map it's
not looking as nice as I think it can be
so we'll go to the dirt map here the
dirt node and we'll take the strengths
down to just two so it's a bit more
subtle all right I'm taking the
transform we'll go 0.08 0.05 just to
scale things down a little bit more and
let's just see if we can get that dirt
in the corner to only be where the rain
is I think that would be nice so I mean
but I guess the rain is gonna pull up in
the corners no matter what hmm
wonder what the best bet on this is
let's let's try it though let's try just
to get the dirt in the corners only
where the rain is so how I would do that
let's think about this for a second we
let's see let's see
so we only want this dirt
we want to subtract
shoot okay this is getting yeah this is
this is where the advanced part comes in
this is where my brain starts to hurt
see if I make the most sense of this so
this is our rain is showing up on all of
this we only want the corners to be
darker only at these little parts where
it's white along the corner so basically
you want this to fade out so maybe
instead of adding let me let me try
throwing a multiply in here
yeah that's it that's it that's where we
want our extra dirt okay so what I did
was I took our dirt layer and I put it
into a multiply along with our rain
layer and that's giving us just this
band of dirt which is just in the rain
okay so I think what we want to do is
combine these together let's see what
this looks like
okay so it's bears yeah that's barely
getting that there so we want to have we
want to combine these the add is
everything but we want to remove it
let's see we want to remove this bit so
whoa
would this work okay do we subtract this
and and this and that's what we do
yeah this is getting us into some crazy
experimenting here what if we invert
that no that's not what we need to do
what if we invert this well okay that's
that's insane hmm how do I remove this
dirt where there's white and double down
on the other dirt in the rain boy this
is tough
do we add it again
there we go I think it's actually
working now you can see how there the
rain is a bit darker here in the corners
yeah it's I'm adding these together so
it's kind of more intense in the corner
bits there as you can see
and you can adjust the dirt map to be
able to kind of open up how far that
goes so if we take the radius to like
three that's going to just make that
dirt in the corners more intense if we
set it to ten you know or twenty
whatever we can start to open up where
that dirt pulls up and gets into yeah
that's pretty sweet I'm feeling that now
here's another trick again we'll use the
the fall-off node to just be able to
tell this thing like hey only stick to
the tops of everything but everything on
the bottom like the dirt isn't gonna
collect on the underside of things it's
more gonna just hit the top and collect
in the corners so what we'll do is we'll
use a fall-off node to do that just like
we did with the rust so let's just take
a second here to clean things up and
right-click auto arrange and then we'll
select the hierarchy that's our diffuse
all of this is going into the diffuse
and we'll do the same for bump we'll
select it just like the hierarchy will
auto arrange it yeah
alright now let's see if we can
incorporate a fall-off node so we only
want this rain is the dirt just the
dirty parts of the rain to be on the top
in the corners so let's take the
fall-off and pipe it into diffuse and
see what's happening let's solo it this
is how you get a nice car paint shader
you can say that like all of basically
like the speckles and all that are
happening on the outside but on the
inside it's just pure reflection so by
default this kind of sets like a car
shader set up but if we set it to normal
versus vector 180 it's just gonna hit
either the top or bottom and again like
with the cast iron will set the fall-off
direction to negative one that way it's
just hitting the top so let's disable
the solo on that you can see how it's
working now we should be able to just
set this to multiply if we combine this
fall-off in texture - with fall off or
with this whole tree we made in texture
one when we pipe that multiply into
diffuse and unsolo oh wait hold on it
wasn't so low okay that's not working
because multiply is probably not the
tool for the job I'm gonna switch the
order to confirm it's not the tool for
the job
let's try add I think ad will probably
do it
and there we go it looks like it's doing
something like it's I wonder if I need
to invert it cuz it yeah it looks like
there isn't any dirt on top but there's
dirt on the bottom so we need to invert
that fall-off node again so let's take
the fall-off let's just go back to one
and now I think hopefully should be
working I'm seeing dirt in the rain up
here but I'm not seeing dirt in the rain
down here so confirmed it is working
sweet and this is all based off of a
texture I built a couple months back
based off of an image it's all about
basing it off of a reference image okay
so this this feels really fun to me I
think this can be applied to different
stuff let's let's take I don't know
let's grab some like a landscape or
something
I'll scale it way down and we'll just
make this a bit more dramatic we'll take
the the rough and fine furrows up to a
hundred percent and we'll give it more
segments and let's apply the material to
it and see what it looks like so this is
rain that is running down like a pane of
glass so going side to side here looks a
little weird but it looks like it's
doing its job like in the crevices it's
actually darker which is really cool
just it's totally what we want and we
could go one extra level here and give
the reflection a bit more variety right
so let's see if we let's go back to our
sphere let's go back to our image or our
texture okay and we want to mess with
the roughness so let's just pull out a
noise map
pipe it into the again iusually pipe
things into diffuse and set the contrast
to 100 so I can actually see what we're
doing and again we'll make those
projection and transform nodes
projection with noise always XYZ to UVW
it makes it seamless and transform we'll
take down like again so this is our this
is our we're breaking up the reflections
I think we can go with a little bit
something larger and we can go into the
noise let's set the Omega to one the
octaves to ten and I think that'll be
pretty nice
maybe maybe Omega 0.8 now I like one and
maybe we scale this up a little bit more
and this is how will will break up our
our reflection so let's pipe in our
diffuse tree that we made here okay and
we'll go and take our noise and pipe
that into roughness and what it's gonna
do if we solo it it might be the
opposite of what I'm about to say but
anything that's black is completely
matte anything that's white is
completely reflective okay but let's see
if we can set up our environments so
that we can actually tell the difference
I'm gonna take out the diffuse to make
things easier I'm going to take out the
bump to make things easier and I'm going
to set the color of this to black and
now we can actually see you know this
noise map that is breaking up our our
roughness so it looks like if I were to
solo this anything that's white is
completely rough anything that's black
is like fully reflective so this is a
little too bright then in our case let's
set the gamma let's bring it down and we
don't want anything to be completely
rough because again if this is covered
in rain it's gonna be glossy pretty much
all the way across certain parts might
just be glossy ER than others so what
we'll do to make sure that this white
isn't entirely just white
we'll go and add a gradient node which
again is like levels will set black or
I'm sorry will set white probably to mid
gray and if we solo it you can see how
the white goes to a mid gray and the
black we can actually crank up and just
say that you know it's just fully
reflective like the water is just hit it
perfectly and we'll just say both solo
and you can see how it kind of breaks up
breaks that up a little bit we can go to
the noise
[Music]
maybe we take the gamma we work the
gamma a little bit more so there's a bit
more gray values here and let's actually
take the contrast back something like
this
and you can see how that starts to look
a little bit more wet and the more we
bring in the black slider the more
things get like super glossy super wet
so that just breaks up the roughness a
little bit and adds a bit more more
character to our texture so we'll drag
in the bump again and we'll drag in the
diffuse again and it's very subtle but
when this thing is in motion when it's
moving around you can you can tell those
those details really count for something
and that's basically it guys those are
two pretty advanced texture setups here
in octane but it's things that you guys
can take and transfer to any program any
renderer so I hope you guys learned
something I hope you guys see like how
crazy texturing can get and how fun it
is like it's all really like a puzzle
for me and I enjoy that aspect of it so
much so two more things here before we
dip out um oh you're saying ice you
wanna make ice I want to make ice okay
um let's try it real quick let's just
try it I'm gonna make let's see this
will be fun should be pretty simple
let's do a new scene let's start from
scratch I'm gonna just drop in a new
HDRI and well I don't know we'll just
grab any one of these filled barrels all
right we'll render we're not gonna see
anything except for hgri and let's make
a cube because that's what you know it's
an ice cube and we'll give it a little
fell it little fillet subdivide yeah
three is fine we'll kind of crank it up
here like an ice cube and then I'm gonna
hold let's see let's give it some
segments let's go ten by ten let's hold
shift and drop in a displacer let's go
shading and give it some noise and let's
scale up this noise
something like that maybe like that's
like kind of like an IceCube this will
be pretty simple so make a specular
material in octane that's like glass
right you drop it in and right out the
gates it kind of looks like an ice cube
um let's see I feel like an ice cube
kind of has an element of subsurface
scattering where like the inside gets a
little bit more thick and it's harder to
see through but on the edges you can see
through it a lot more and again you're
have to reference an ice cube for this
but I'm just gonna try here right off
the bat and see if I can't get this
looking nice let's open up this specular
material and if you don't see anything
you can click get active material if you
still don't see anything go view frame
all and then I'll get you there so you
know we can grab a noise node and pipe
it into the roughness again projection
and transform always with with noise
nodes XYZ - uvw take the transform let's
solo it so we can see what's going on we
can't see anything let's take the
contrast to a hundred so we can see
something and it looks pretty tiny right
here let's maybe scale up with the
transform we'll go five and let's set
the Omega to one octaves to ten and that
kind of breaks it up there maybe the
gamma can be set to one point two so we
have a little bit more of we still don't
see anything I don't know if that's an
octane bug or what let's take transform
let's go up even more set the contrast
to like five and then let's give it like
a gradient and just kind of chill out
one of these I don't know which one yet
if we make it all white then that's okay
we need to go the other way so when you
take white and go like mid gray so
that's a quick quick IceCube but if you
want to do it I feel like the best way
to do this would be to actually use a
medium here so if we go to medium and we
go to absorption and scattering right
let's get rid of the roughness for a
second and let's take a look at what
this is doing so absorption and
scattering it's basically like filling
it up with like a little cloud right the
density is 100 if we set that to zero we
should be able to see it right through
let's try sending it to one okay so
that's kind of filling it up a little
bit let's give some RGB spectrums here
we actually need to pipe some stuff in
absorption let's control drag and
scattering so scattering I think does
the opposite of the color you put in so
if I take scattering and we set it to
like a blue it should go yellow yeah it
gets kind of crazy so let's chill out on
that for a second let's go to the
absorption and say the absorption let's
just set to like a neutral like a mid
kind of gray but if it's an IceCube
let's see
let's adjust these scattering settings
I feel like it's the RGB spectrum on the
scattering that's doing what we wanted
to do here and we can just set these
colors so this is maybe more like a
turquoise blueish kind of color it's
maybe more like an IceCube and I think
if you go to common fake shadows I think
that I forget what that does I think it
helps with like light and stuff but it's
just too glossy I feel like it needs
more reflection or more roughness so
let's just pipe that roughness in and
that yeah still doesn't feel right this
is what I would help or when the
reference would help you see what an ice
cube looks like so I'm just gonna pull
it up real quick and see ice cube not
the rapper Ice Cube block
yeah these are like stock images here
[Music]
huh that's cool you can see what I mean
by the the scattering you know it's it's
harder to see on the inside but on the
outsides you're able to see through a
little bit more same real looks so
photoshopped
oh it has bump it has bump definitely so
we would want to give it some bump so
you can just I don't know pipe this
noise into the bump as well I feel like
the roughness is a little intense
and these settings are so finicky yeah
you guys can see you can go to town with
all this and spend forever but I you
know we don't have all the time in the
world to spend on this that's kind of
the idea though it's kind of the stuff
you'd be one to mess with um so yeah
textures the best you can make anything
you want um so you guys know that we do
a weekly challenge here and I'm gonna
announce the winners right but before I
announce the winners I want to let you
guys know or fill you in on this next
weekly challenge so I challenge all of
you you have one week to go outside take
some pictures with your iPhone your
Android whatever find a texture outside
that you think looks awesome and that
you think would be fun and challenging
to recreate in whatever program you want
okay take the picture include your
reference image all right and then
create that texture from scratch and go
ahead and post that image post the
reference image and even take a picture
of your node tree okay
try to keep all of trying to keep it
completely what is it physically based
right so try and do it from noise maps
and stuff you don't want to just
download an image from or a texture from
mega scans or something try and create
this yourself with noise maps it's
really fun it's actually really really
cool I understand that you can't really
do everything as you guys saw here with
like the rain I needed that image of the
rain but definitely um you know try and
make it from scratch try and work on it
yourself and put some time into it and
you know show me your texture on a
couple different objects and how it
works across the board and I think it'd
be really fun yeah it'd be super cool
maybe uh I don't know
the winners are cool with giving out
their textures or something to people or
maybe we'll get some I don't know I'm
still trying to figure out the prize
thing but we'll figure that out we'll
figure that out in time so that's that's
the challenge to you guys I'll restate
the challenge once I announce the
winners of this last week's weekly
challenge just so we make sure
everyone's clear so yeah the last week's
weekly challenge was to tell a story
through a chrome ball right which is
kind of out there it's kind of a very
interesting topic and I gave the example
of who did it was a chrome ball pencil
drawing by was it it was I think I was
dolly no I wasn't dolly it was a assure
yes Oh hold on the cat's just opened up
the screen door let me take care of that
so I gave this as an example to tell a
story through a chrome ball and this is
obviously this super cool image here
if I can zoom in you can see here it's a
little story going on he's in a room
drew his hand it's super cool super
super cool so that was the proper last
week and before I announce the winners I
just want to give a quick shout out to
one that I thought was really cool you
didn't make it but you got really close
and I'll tell you why this is John
Malcolm here on the discord server and I
think this is a really really nice image
you did a really great job with all of
your textures and your composition is
very nice your lighting is very nice
like this texture here is great
fantastic but again the prompt was to
tell a story through through a chrome
ball and I'm just not really getting a
story here as much as I would have liked
you can tell that it's like you know
they're doing some polishing but it was
really close like this is really like
this is nice this looks really really
nice you can tell here that you combined
on this cloth with this like LED almost
or polish with like a mix material it
looks super super nice definitely
missing some surface imperfections here
on this wood handle but I guess that's
the point you're kind of polishing all
this stuff but god this looks so nice
right here this is great and this
displacement map here you have or this
bump map is great too very close John
Malcolm very very close you're just
looking for more of a story so without
further ado let's get to our five
winners of the weekly challenge guys and
we will start here with salumi this is
freaking awesome like this is great it's
not a render certainly not a render
looks like a Photoshop drawing but hey
that's okay you know the point is to do
your thing work on your passion work on
your artistic creative passion and
that's exactly what tsunami did here
telling a story the story of Indian
Jones sneaking into the temple trying to
switch out the chrome ball for the sack
of
I don't know whatever's in sand or
something this is great yeah I really
dig this I think this is you did a
really really good job here I think it's
unique and it's nice to see some
drawings and paintings here on these
weekly challenges so that's a fair game
guys great work
Zulu me congratulations you are a weekly
challenge winner so you'll be getting
the role of challenge winner this week
stealing it stealing it from someone who
else who won the other week so you got
earned back next up guys we have an
image by gold this is so so so so cool
so unique
great story this guy got detached from
ISS or whatever and it's floating on
space very scary a very very scary
situation and he was like you know what
for the purists out there who who just
wanted the chrome ball then he rendered
out a chrome ball version of it but I
think this works perfect this is a
chrome ball this is it's the same thing
and there's just a lot more context like
I think out of everyone who joined this
challenge gold you took the cake here
like you gave it context complete
context it just looks so cool like you
did a really really good job you have
your surface imperfections down here
just slight slight surface imperfections
the motion blur adds a lot a whole lot
it's the great work fantastic work next
up we have we have job congrats for
winning the the weekly challenge super
cool he based his images off of Blade
Runner here I made some really nice
renders here I love the lighting the
composition is nice and you could tell
it was like really rainy and moody here
because you can see the dry drain
surface imperfection and I'm diggin it
you got this guy just kind of lost out
in this world and I think you did a
fantastic job Joe
congratulations you are a weekly
challenge winner second-to-last here in
no particular order right we got visual
with this image here and it took me a
moment to realize what the heck was
going on I'd really look at it um so I
saw this I was like what's she doing
oh she's holding a selfie stick she's
holding this chrome ball and it looks
like it's a scene from Jurassic Park
because you have these Raptors in the
kitchen right and you got her brother
over here hiding from these Raptors as
well they're in the kitchen it's that
scene you guys remember the scene and
what a great story you told the story
through the chrome ball you got the
surface imperfections here the scratches
the fingerprints all that good stuff
it'd be nice to get a little bit of glow
here I think would be cool maybe be
scaled down your surface imperfections a
little bit there a little you can see a
little bit of pixelization in there but
you even got the background in here got
pots and model this whole kitchen or
found a kitchen set or something I don't
know you did a really good job you got
characters like it's very very hard to
do characters but at least you got the
emotion going on here and you got the
scenario you told the story so congrats
visual you are a challenge winner this
week and last but not least we have damn
D damn D this is simple it's very simple
and very subtle believe that you got
your photo scan gentlemen in business
attire and you have a skull here is he
like what is he doing you know is he
visiting a gravesite did he put this
skull here did he miss it entirely I
don't know but I think this is really
great it's simple you know could
definitely use a little bit of surface
imperfections here on the sand or I'm
sorry on the on the ball but yeah your
sand textures not bad definitely look
into our D textures for the highest
quality
photoscan textures but yeah I dug this I
like the composition it looks looks like
a phone background definitely but hey
you told a story that was the point and
this whole thing and you did a good job
with lighting and Composition so
congrats to you
damn d you are a challenge winner this
week so that's it guys thank you for
particular yeah I've been going for too
long
thanks for participating I hope you guys
had fun putting all this together and I
hope you guys are gonna have some fun
making your own physically-based
texture this week so um one thing that
was brought to my attention last week
when I announced the winners I found out
that one of the winners basically
watched a tutorial and you know went
through the tutorial and posted that
work as their as their their image you
know and a lot of you guys felt like you
were cheated like oh you know just
follow this tutorial and posted the
exact image from the tutorial and I
spent all week doing my thing so a
couple things to that point okay so
first off um you know I understand you
guys who who feel like you put a lot of
time into it and then you had somebody
who just follow tutorial and posted
their image you know from the tutorial
just straight straight out the tutorial
I know that that's how I learned in the
past all I did was follow the tutorials
and do Andrew Kramer tutorials and you
know I just copied andrew kramer's work
one to one because that's what you do
when you fall is follow a tutorial now
posting it as like your work is probably
not the best move you would want to say
hey I followed a tutorial for this so I
think in the future for the rest of
these challenges
if you use any sort of reference or
tutorial I'd ask that you post that let
me know if you are just going right off
a tutorial but also you you really want
to watch a tutorial maybe follow the
tutorial exactly all the way through for
the first time but if you're gonna post
anything as your work switch it up like
take the tools you're learning and apply
it to your own art you know push
yourself to make things your own and
that's that's really something that I
tried to do with you know any Andrew
Kramer tutorial
it's so obvious when you see someone's
work or someone's demo reel and you see
oh I know all these tutorials they just
followed the tutorials like you know
what's more impactful is to see the
actual like how you took the tutorial
and you flipped it and applied it to new
footage new techniques a new situation
and you made it your own now that's the
most important thing is making it your
own again I've done it I I do a lot of
drawing okay the easiest way for me when
I started out was to draw other people's
drawings and I'd post it and I'd say hey
look at the drawing I did it was just
the fastest way for me to learn how to
draw is to draw other people's drawings
and it didn't take like it took it took
years and years and years and years and
years and years until I was able to draw
something on my own and I basically got
to the point where I would take a
picture of something and I would draw
that picture that I took so it makes it
more personal and you know if you want
to sell your art you can sell that if
you want to claim full I guess I know
it's not plagiarism you're not
plagiarizing saying like it's a fine
line you know it's a super fine line if
yeah I don't know I don't know it is it
is tough I just think at the end of the
day you don't want to claim like a
tutorial having copied at one to one as
your work cuz you're just following a
tutorial which is again which is fine
okay that's that's how you learn so
don't stop following tutorials but if
you're gonna post something saying this
is my work just make sure you followed a
tutorial and took the tools from that
and applied it to your own ideas that's
the point right so I think you guys get
what I'm saying just in the future okay
when we're doing these challenges I ask
that you either provide a clay render
okay
or that you provide like in this case a
view of your node tree so I can see
what's going on alright
and if you're following tutorials make
it your own don't just post the tutorial
alright so with all that with all that
yeah this week's challenge is to make
your own procedural texture use noise
Maps don't use mega scans images alright
make it your own I'll be here for the
next five minutes chillin with you guys
if you have any questions and I may have
I may have missed the super chat that
one of you guys uh threw my way and if I
did I'm sorry but I appreciate you thank
you so much yeah any questions guys any
questions at all there's a janky ice
cube for you go
yeah visual I think you said it best
tutorial should be used to learn the
skills not to show your skills yeah and
guys the difference between shader and
texture boy I don't know a texture might
be like a black and white image like
that rain texture maybe that's a texture
a shader is probably a series of
textures combined together to produce
like like the the cast iron the rusted
cast iron like that's a shader I feel
like don't give me don't quote me a
hundred percent on that let me grab a
kombucha before we leave here ooh
louisa ass do you have any
recommendations for what film to use i'm
starting out and got got a wee to go got
it a we got we a we ago a week ago yes
I'll be right back let me grab the
kombucha and I'll answer your question
um Christian thank you
I got the Cayenne cleanse going right
now always feel healthy with this stuff
um yeah dude you can you can use
substance painter you can use blender
you can use whatever program you want
seriously it's totally fine just make
your own physically-based shader okay
that's all I ask
base it off a reference footage please
please do that you need to provide your
reference image with all right
with the final shader that you create so
just make sure you have both of those
when you submit it be cool to find a
prize for you guys to let me let me see
if I can hit up let me see if I can hit
up like greyscale gorilla or something
and see if I can't find a a prize maybe
like the everyday materials collection
let me let me talk let me see if I can
get that going for a prize this week I
don't I can't guarantee it alright but I
know the guys at greyscale they're
really chill and I think they would be
down for something like this
okay so let me see what I can do um okay
so what film I use I luv Sinha still 800
t that is ooh let me show you all I love
shooting film soon is still 800 T it's
like the Blade Runner kind of kind of
film stock you know this is 35
millimeter film camera right here is the
nikkor matte FTN but yeah the the set of
still a hundred t can see this nice look
right here it's really good for night
with rain it gives you those like kind
of tungsten mid-tones those blue shadows
I love it so much oh boy like this right
here mm-hmm
wonderful so that's a good one that's a
good color stock Cinna still also has
50d which is a nice daytime color here
something like this something like this
I just love it like this right here I
love that look so much so good this is
another 800 T porch or 400 is another
good color that's more accessible all
right and then as far as black and white
goes I really like T max team X 400 it's
very contrast II I like it a lot
really really nice black and white stock
Ilford 5 HP I think HP 5 ilford HP 5 is
another good black and white stock super
contrast ease well nice vibes there yeah
those are my go-to those are my goat
cheese Luisa thanks for the question
okay mr. dam 236 I've never used the
reference image until now do you think
do you think I do it will be more easier
and faster a reference image is like
your base truth a reference image you
can always look back to to like yeah as
a base truth I know like it's your
guiding source the whole time you're
making something whether you're doing an
edit whether you're doing a visual
effect whether you're doing a texture
whether you know whatever you're
creating it's always nice to have a
reference image because that is true to
life and that's going to give you the
most accurate and realistic results to
be able to come up with something off
the top of your head is nearly
impossible just please use use a
reference
unless you're Kim Jung ji and can just
draw stuff like this from the top of
your head please
use reference this guy is amazing he
does everything from his brain
[Music]
yeah look at this this is incredible
this artwork is insane if you guys look
him up on Instagram Kim Jung ji a video
of him yeah look at this he just does it
from his head well I guess he is
referencing some stuff here but his
thing usually his thing is to just draw
stuff from his head and he just goes and
he uses a pen and it's just incredible
so much detail yeah this guy's a master
that's about it guys that's about all I
got today so good luck to everybody and
I called it it's pretty close to ours in
52 minutes um yeah if you guys enjoyed
this video if you enjoy hanging out go
ahead and subscribe if you're not leave
a comment down below let me know what
you guys want me to do next time
I always need help figuring out what
y'all want to learn I want to make sure
that I'm passionate about it and I want
to make sure that you guys need the
knowledge so commenting about what you
guys want helps me a lot if you're not a
part of the discord server there's a
link in the description below join up
join the weekly challenge post your
submission to the discord server there's
a whole little channel thing for it too
anything else yeah I'm still working on
that HDRI tutorial it's gonna be awesome
a surface imperfection tutorial is it's
in the brain it's even typed out a
little bit and I'll for the next two
weeks I'm gonna be working on the
Dominos video for corridor it's gonna be
crazy it's gonna be a crunch like two
weeks crunch crunch town but I
appreciate you guys thank you for
stopping by and I'll catch you next week
peace guys later